evan rachel wood is speaking out against
her ex-fiance
on monday the 33 year old actress posted
this to instagram a note claiming that
marilyn manson whom evan began dating in
2007
and got engaged to in 2010 groomed
and abused her during their relationship
which began when she was 19
and he was 38. i just have to kind of
believe that
that i can do it and i believe in people
and i believe in in the power of
platforms and
if i even have this a little bit of
power that i can use for good right now
at such a crucial time in history and
and for women's rights and civil rights
then i want to be a part of that
e.t has reached out to manson for
comment
quote the name of my abuser is brian
warner also known to the world as
marilyn manson he horrifically abused me
for years
i was brainwashed and manipulated in
submission
i am done living in fear of retaliation
slander or blackmail
i am here to expose this dangerous man
and call out the many industries that
have enabled him before he ruins
any more lives i stand with the many
victims who will no longer be silent
wood has previously spoken out about her
experience with domestic abuse
but hadn't named an alleged abuser until
now
while giving a testimony before congress
in 2018
wood claimed she had been raped more
than once
i struggled with depression addiction
agoraphobia night terrors
i struggled with self-harm to the point
of two suicide attempts which landed me
in a psychiatric hospital for a short
period of time
while manson has yet to respond to
wood's recent claims
his team released a statement in
november 2020
after questions about the actress's
testimony before congress in 2018
and the california senate public safety
committee in 2019
came up during an interview the
musician's rep said in part
quote personal testimony is just that
and we think it's inappropriate to
comment on that
on her instagram story evan shared
screenshots of a september 2020 twitter
thread by dan
cleary who was in manson's touring band
when wood was around
quote over the course of one year he
turned her into a different person
he broke her wood also shared
screenshots of posts by manson's other
accusers
all of whom said they suffer from ptsd
as a result of their alleged experience
with a musician
ashley walters and ashley lindsey morgan
claimed they suffered sleep deprivation
while sarah mcneely alleged that manson
quote
threatened to bash my face in with a
baseball bat
i'd like to say to my attackers that i
don't hate you
i feel sorry for you i'm not here to
shame you
i want to understand you and i want you
to understand me but you have to listen
first
you